et maintenant voici vous faire plaisir
vous qui avez fait beaucoup de haut en
bas les parents de bol est il arrivé là
c'est l'idole de tout le monde c'est le
plus grand de tous
tu es là on a beaucoup parlé de vous
avec costantini d'ailleurs ouais bah oui
donc vous êtes capitaine de l'équipe de
france de handball qui est championne du
monde et ça ça vous savez comment on
fait un triomphe comme un triomphe
romain
et voilà bravo on n'en finit pas parce
que mercredi à marseille
vous avez battu la slovénie 31 27 à la
mi-temps ici à 15 14
ce n'était pas gagné du tout et vous
vous avez trois cent cinquante
sélections presque 350 sélections en
équipe de france
vous êtes le deschamps du handball ont
dit c'est ça ça vous va comme définition
hausse à l'honneur pour moi ouais
et si on veut vous voir on peut voir en
ce moment donc au tournoi de paris du 8
au 10 juin suivant en plein plein fin de
saison et on a encore le bercy pour nous
c'est un moyen de se retrouver par
rapport à ce qu'on a pu faire au mois de
février on trouve n'a publié que je
pense qu'il n'y a pas meilleur
mais enfin façon de récompenser le
comprends qu'on a eu un mois de février
alors que quelqu'un ici qui nous a
beaucoup parlé de vous on va voir ce
qu'il a dit vous partez mais tout le
monde sera là non je sais pas moi je
suis un grand spécialiste du handball
mais ont-ils cazals richardson martin
s'en vont bon inutile c'est sur les
autres on va essayer un petit peu de fr
revenir sur leur décision parce qu'ils
sont quand même encore indispensable
parce que vous aidiez emballant de
richardson c'est lui qui a permis de
gravir les échelons définitif oui c'est
un mec exceptionnel exceptionnel que
celui du bambou
expliquer maintenant est comment j'ai
pas eu l'occasion de passer en espagne à
paris nous ne devons plus nous voilà à
vous étaient vachement sympa avec lui
parce qu'aux championnats du monde
pendant la cérémonie de remise des
médailles vous êtes allé le chercher et
vous l'avez fait monter sur le podium
parce que c'était son dernier match en
tant que patron de l'équipe de france
depuis 92 on a enfin moi j'ai commencé à
vraiment remporter un titre c'est un 92
à barcelone
et depuis on a à chaque fois il avait
toujours été à l'écart de tout notre
avancée comme c'était son dernier je
suis dit autant il fait ce moment là
avec nous quant à lui la fin des barjots
costantini il a quand même fait un peu
le ménage dans l'équipe de france vous
il vous a gardé pour les costauds donc
l'équipe suivante alors vous êtes les
jackson richardson donc richardson c'est
un nom 600 colons en fait c'est des
colons laussac sens parce que souvent
les esclaves avaient le nom de leur
mettre une certaine façon c'était la
réunion donc vous êtes né et puis
jackson c'est parce que votre mère à
jour a vu un film et c'est je suis pas
citer le héros où l'acteur qui
s'appelait jackson dans tous les cas de
vous appeler jackson était enceinte de
vous moi je pense que la durée un film
j'aime pas vraiment posé la question aux
journalistes mais moi je ne suis je me
rends vraiment renseigné quoi leur site
né en 1969 au sud de l'île de la réunion
à saint pierre votre père et noir ils
s'appellent comme mon fils il s'appelle
gaston votre mère est blanche elle
s'appelle rose marie ce qu'il faut dire
oui c'est que votre père était un ancien
basketteur 1
et puis il était gardien dans le foot
aussi pompier votre père et son ambition
c'était qu'ils ont sorti par le sport
même ligne comme
comme ils disent et savait pas c'est pas
très bien très bien écrire et si vous
savez pas lire alors pour lui ça ça
réussit à lui c'était dans le sport à la
force n ya toujours chez les enfants je
peux dès le plus jeune âge les faits
trois sports le handball le football et
le basketball et des progrès mais il y
gère vous dire c'est un jury toutes les
équipes de handball du monde voudrait
avoir
jackson dans leur équipe et il rit je
tiens un truc du tu sais pas tu as pris
quelques cours de golf un jour j'ai
rencontré le mec est usé du practice
il a dit j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
c'est à dire au bout de 5 6
drive il tapé dans la balle quand c'est
évidemment une coordination incroyable
et tout donc voilà c'est ça c'est il
faut dire merci papa et à maman va
casser ce qui fait votre force c'est
quand même justement de la fusion des
trois sports dont le fait d avoir
pratiqué tous les trois d'un très bon
niveau
c'est bien ce qui fait votre
particularité ce que je me dis à chaque
fois enfin on nous dit femmes
différencie des autres sportifs ou deux
autres des hôtes en valeur je dis
peut-être la force en moi c'est d'avoir
pratiqué ce sport à l'école c'était pas
terrible non pas vraiment d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça maintenant
j'ai dû tout à tous les jeunes de que ne
faut surtout pas les études parce que le
6 mai parce que maintenant je voulais
voeckler elle vous est possible que vous
ayez un entraînement très tard le soir
et quand vous rentriez tard lendemain
matin elle vous réveiller à 6 heures
pour faire fi de tout arrêter
non mais moi je serai bon elle a essayé
en tous les cas un bal c'est encore un
sport on gagne beaucoup de sous et même
si tu es une star et c'est d'ailleurs
notre spécialité
si jackson était dans n'importe quel
autre spécialité ou legueulle basket et
où ils seraient milliardaire et puis
alors vous arrivez au bataillon de
joinville à l'âge de 19 ans pour faire
votre service militaire très dur
d'arriver à cessieu enfin moi j'étais
tellement que fier et content le dell
devenu art métropole et les trois
premiers jours j'ai pas j'ai pas réalisé
comme si après que j'ai l'âge et les
plus ma famille
lever à l'heure le matin vous dites
toujours la métropole alors que les
corses u10 la france ça vous dit tout
sur la métropole
alors ce qui était très sympa c'est que
les joueurs sont cotisés pour vous payez
votre billet d'avion pour retourner à la
réunion pour noël et alors deux ans
après votre arrivée en 90 première
sélection en équipe de france avait
effectivement assez vite
vous faites plusieurs clubs dont cannes
hier vitrolles vous amener aux
championnats d'europe en 93 et puis
l'allemagne parce que l'allemagne se la
mère patrie du du handball
grosswallstadt vous jouez un crunch
jacques levy m'attends pas plus loin
mais l'important c'est